very very exciting new project I really
found a new passion in a new direction
which is great I'm very happy about that
and and it really started in mobility
because in mobility especially cars with
going to electric cars and autonomous
cars there's it's so fascinating the
disruption is happening there the new
technologies are coming and also the
ability to have an impact in that space
yeah for our planet for our society is
huge and I love this combination and
this is really the next step of that
that we're now creating this global hub
for all future positive technologies at
the airport in Berlin and it's not just
mobility it goes into it goes into
fashion one day there will be energy
there's all these different all these
different steps it's even food there's
even food technologies which are very
very important part in this so this is
Nika there are lots of green tech events
out there what's different about your
one I don't think there are actually
there's a lot of Technology events but
green technology there's not and this is
why we see an opportunity there because
the moment is so perfect for that
because at the moment all this stuff is
so damn fascinating and in effect it's
like a Consumer Electronics Show in
Vegas but with a purpose because we want
to have impact with our event and
there's an opportunity there because if
you can if you can go with fascination
and fascinate all of us it will
encourage us to embrace those those
technologies and that's gonna speed up
progress and positive change and we all
know that's super important at the
moment I just met Sir David Attenborough
in divorce and he said it's the eleventh
hour for all of us I was just gonna ask
you about divorce because do you sense
that world leaders and crucially the
people who are sitting on you know the
world's assets and are they feeling
while Rome burns I mean there's a lot of
lip service being paid to the need to
address environmental concerns do you
get the sense that people are really
doing anything about it
well in Davos this year again there was
the number one topic and there's a lot
of progress really it's impressive it's
just such a large issue that it takes a
lot of time and and we still need to
make a lot more progress and get more
people knowledgeable about it even and
ma'am
make it more tangible as well because in
the end it's each of us individuals that
can that can make probably the biggest
difference if we all make a little
little bit of an effort and that's
really the mission to get it out to
everybody and get the message out get
everybody involved but it's happening
and is exactly there where we want to
support a lot of the green technology
there is still very much at venture
stage isn't it and with with high risks
attached to it and a lot of the biggest
pots of money are the pots of money
which are not allowed to invest in the
risky thing so how do you get over that
barrier yeah no I mean yes and no it's
true that in Europe specifically like
pension funds are not really allowed to
invest in startups and that's quite a
something that's been limiting Europe a
lot and it's in its progress compared to
like China and America but in terms of
green technologies if you look at like
the banking world everybody is rolling
out these impact funds green technology
funds so I think there's a lot of
progress there and people in the
financial world are seeing that actually
it's not even a compromise in terms of
returns anymore
the best opportunity for business is in
impact impact investments so business
and impact is the biggest there so it's
a no-brainer
and this is a great great direction that
we're all heading in in the financial
world so when will petrol and diesel
cars be a thing of the past and what
does that mean for Formula One well
there's still there's still a long way
to go and then petrol and diesel both in
their own way still have a of course a
space there but it's it's a process I
think electric cars are coming very very
quick in 10 years time probably like 50
percent of all cars will be electric two
ones are sold and exactly in that point
also Formula One will start to need to
question their their their powertrain
because they need to stay and in the in
the in the moment yeah and I would call
it at site-geist even Formula One and so
I'm sure one day they have to consider
going electric the problem is that
Formula e has the rights to electric
racing so maybe there has to be a merger
than one day